Hannah brown makes out in a plane gets
lathered up on a boat and two guys admit
they're in love as the Bachelorette
heads to hometowns tell me you love me
it felt really good nice
Hannah was on the move during this
week's episode of The Bachelorette as
she got to know her Final Four Peter
Tyler Luke P and Jed on a deeper level
by meeting their families I love you Jed
dropped that bombshell while at a
recording studio in his hometown of
Knoxville Tennessee which left Hannah on
cloud nine for a minute meeting Jed's
family was rocky as his parents and
sister expressed their concerns over Jed
balancing his music career and his
romantic relationship with Hannah I'm
very protective over Jed and making
music makes them so happy and honestly
like him potentially falling in love
with you I'm like I'm not sure that it's
a good thing to say him
considering it's a little surprising I
did not get the validation that I
thought I want to get earlier in the
episode in Luke peas hometown of
Gainesville Georgia he also admitted
he's in love and Hanna's reaction was
surprising I was falling in love with
him I knew that I just wanted to be able
to really just figure everything out for
myself and you'll see me do that I take
the information that I'm giving in and I
just trust throughout the process that I
will be able to make my own decisions
with the information I didn't in my
discernment in my end time Hannah also
got to hang with Abbott astok Tyler in
Jupiter Florida
there's no
sexual attraction between Tyler and I
and I think he's super high and got
emotional
as Tyler reunited with his family
including his dad who was struggling
with cancer before he left for the show
my dad getting sick you know almost
dying you know it put a lot of things in
perspective it's like I want my dad to
see my wife his family loved Hannah and
gave them their blessing
speaking of Titor he got me worried
about it why are you worried because
yeah the look on his face it you guys
seemed so happy together I don't know he
might be loved didn't expect that yeah
because Tyler's I wanna let many people
he called Westlake Village native Peter
took his relationship with Hannah to new
heights showing off his pilot skills and
even making out with the former pageant
princess in the sky I don't know if I've
had the time to know who my person is
here because I need more time but Hannah
had a hard time sending anyone home as
it came down to Jed and Luke P in the
final two gentlemen Hannah
the roses you asked for
[Music]
I want to continue on with all of you so
it seems they're all heading to Greece
for fantasy suites and we'll finally get
to see a witch lucky man and got to know
Hannah even better in that infamous
windmill
we did it just take it town I can tell
you I'm
[Music]